in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit. Amen!
The reading from the Sinaxadion for April 29th, on which we commemorate,
our Holy Father Basil, Bishop of Ostrog.
Our Holy Father Basil was born in the year 1610 of poor but deeply devout parents
in the village of Merconik in Herzegovina.
His first school of piety was his parental home, where the things of God were of more importance
than earthly and fleeting cares, and the second in which his soul was able to satisfy
its spiritual aspirations was regular attendance at the divine liturgy,
to which personal prayer and solitude was added.
When he entered a church, prostrating deeply to the ground and devoutly kissing it,
he followed the divine liturgy, motionless, and with fear, as though he stood before the throne
of God. Although he was very poor, he always shared his bread with the other boys who went
with him to keep the sheep. To escape the malign influence of those neighbors
who had apostatized from the Christian faith and converted to Islam, his parents sent him to finish
his education in the monastery of Zavala, of which his uncle was the abbot.
Avidly reading the writings of the Holy Fathers, his heart burned for the ascetic life,
and he decided to become a monk. He was transferred in the monastery of Drosch,
and a short time later was ordained Deakin, and then priest.
He was then called to serve with Metropolitan Mardarios of Satini.
At this time, when the Serbs were oppressed under the Turkish Yoke,
the Orthodox faith was also endangered by the propaganda of the Jesuits,
who were seeking to convert them to Catholicism.
St. Basil came to the Metropolitan's attention in connection with this cunning propaganda
and the need to defend Orthodoxy. But the latter was indifferent and falsely accused him
in front of the people. These Calamnes found no echo because the Christians had full confidence
in St. Basil, whose way of life was a radiant testimony to the truth.
On his return to Drosch, the St. traveled round the villages, holding services
and exhorting the people to keep the faith as the most precious possession.
This apostolic work stirred up against Basil the hatred of those who had become Muslims
and they attempted to kill him.
To escape this danger, the saint was forced to flee to Russia.
He returned sometime later with a great many books and liturgical vestments.
But he discovered that the hatred of the Muslims and the uniyods toward him
had in no way abated, and he had to leave again, this time on a pilgrimage to mount Athos.
On his return, he passed through Peck, where Paisios the Serbian Patriarch consecrated him Bishop
and named him Metropolitan of Thrabinje in the year 1638.
The Metropolitan of Herzegovina being assassinated shortly afterwards by the Turks,
St. Basil was appointed to succeed him.
Turkish oppression was at that time redoubling against the Serbian people.
Churches, monasteries and houses were sacked and the whole country was mercilessly devastated.
The Holy Bishop had once more to take flight.
He found refuge in the monastery of Ostrog and settled in the cave that had been occupied
by the Holy Abbate Isaiah.
From this retreat, he directed his diocese for fifteen years,
guiding himself by prayer and lengthy nocturnal intercession before God.
He sometimes left the monastery to visit the afflicted people,
sympathizing with their sufferings and strengthening them in hope.
Many there were who benefited from the miraculous power of his prayer,
and who already venerated him as a saint.
During the great waves of persecution, people went in crowds to Ostrog
to receive spiritual and bodily comfort from the Holy Bishop.
St. Basil had, in addition, to confront the malice of certain Orthodox,
like Prince Raik and his sons, who inspired by the demon,
caused great harm to the monastery and attempted to drive out the man of God.
Basil was patient and predicted to the Prince that all his sons would perish
because of the ills done to the monastery.
When this prophecy was fulfilled, the Prince repented deeply and God gave him new issue.
Indefatigable in his asceses and prayer by which he sustained his people,
St. Basil entered peacefully into rest in the Lord on 29 April,
in the year 1671.
At the moment of his last breath, an indescribable light filled his cell
and then a vine sprouted up on the bare rock near the place where he died.
Many miracles began to be wrought at his grave and have never ceased to this day.
Seven years after his death, St. Basil appeared in his sleep to the abbot
of the monastery of St. Luke of Supa, clad in his episcopal vestments
and with a censor in his hand, and told him to go and open his grave.
While the saint was sensing, pieces of charcoal fell on the abbot,
who woke full of fear and left immediately with his monks for Ostrog.
When they opened the grave, they found the saint's body, the color of wax,
and giving off a fragrance like that of Basil.
They placed his relics in a reliquary in the church of the presentation of the mother of God in the temple,
where pilgrims were able from that time to venerate it.
Just as the saint had never throughout his life known peace,
so his relics had to be hidden a number of times to escape Turkish dispoiling.
In the year 1942, the monastery of Ostrog was bombed out.
Thanks to the saint's protection, the projectiles fell without damaging the buildings.
A shell even landed at the entrance of the saint's cave that had been transformed into a chapel,
where his relics were placed, but it did not explode and can still be seen on that spot.
Saint Basil is one of the most venerated saints among the Serbs.
There are very many churches dedicated to him, both in Serbia and abroad.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.